Changing color like a chameleon. We
all must have heard this saying, when and how does a chameleon
change its color? If we talk about a chameleon,
that is your Chameleon. This is a member of our reptiles.
Basically,
a cell called chromatophore is present in its body,
which  It helps in color change.
Why does it change its color? Firstly, it changes its color to
attract the opposite sex. Well, it
also changes its color to maintain its body temperature and to hide from the predator.  That is
your secondary region but what will be your main region? Attracting the
opposite sex as well as controlling
body temperature. So like
and subscribe the channel for such amazing facts. Thank you.